let's do some equations of lines in
point slope form
point
slope and this is
different from
y or from slope intercept form
from slope intercept form but they
really are just two different ways of
writing the same equation or else we'll
see that with a couple of examples and
you might remember that slope intercept
form were equations of the lines of the
form y is equal to mx
plus b we did this in the last video
where m is the slope b is the intercept
the y intercept that's why it's called
slope intercept you have the slope and
the intercept in point slope form it
takes the form y
is equal to or y minus y
one and i'll tell you what y one is in a
second
is equal to
m
times x minus x one where the coordinate
x one
y1 is a point on the line that's why
this is called point slope form now
these are just two different ways of
writing the exact same thing you can
always algebraically manipulate this to
get that or algebraically manipulate
that to get that and i'll show you that
with a couple of examples but let's just
do a few in point slope form just to
make things concrete in your head
so here we have a line that has slope of
negative one over ten so m is equal to
negative one over ten and it goes
through the point ten comma two
so we can directly go to point slope
form the point slope form here so let's
get a point a point here is the point 10
comma 2.
so we can immediately go to point slope
form y
minus this is a y value that's on the
line so y minus 2 is going to be equal
to the slope
negative 1 over
10
times
x minus an x value times x minus
10 just like that and we're done we just
put it in point slope form and there's
two things i want to point out to you
why this makes 1 why this makes sense
and i also want to show you that this is
equivalent to that so the first thing is
why does this make sense well all this
is saying if you divide both sides of
this equation by that right over there
you get
2
over
x minus 10 is equal to negative 1 over
10. or you get the change in y between
any point and 2 and the point 2 and any
and the change over the change in x so
you get the change in y over the change
in x for any point x y on that line
relative to the point 10 comma 2 is
going to be negative 1 over 10. this is
just the definition
of your slope hopefully i don't confuse
you there i'm just showing you that this
is just using the definition of the
slope to create the equation of the line
now the other thing i want to show you
is that this is completely equivalent to
this we can just algebraically
manipulate this to get that and let's do
that so this right here is the answer
to the problem but let's play around
with it algebraically to get it in that
form so if we get y minus 2 is equal to
let's distribute the negative one over
ten so it's negative one over ten x and
the negative one over ten times negative
ten is plus one now we can add two to
both sides of this equation and you get
y is equal to negative 1 over 10
x
plus 3. so just algebraically
manipulating it we were able to put it
into slope intercept form so these two
things are completely equivalent let's
do a couple more problems
the line contains the points 10 comma 12
and 525 so let's figure out the slope
so the slope which is equal to change in
y over change
in x
is equal to well let's just use this
point first so let's say it's 12
minus
25
12 minus 25
over
over
10
over 10
minus 5
over 10 minus 5.
and this is going to be equal to 12
minus 25 is negative 13
over 10 minus 5 which is
5. so the slope here is negative 13 over
5. let's put in the slope point slope
form the equation so it's going to be y
minus let's use this point right here y
minus 25
is equal to the slope negative 13 over 5
times
x
minus
this point 5.
we just knew that the point
5
comma 25 is on the line so y minus 25 is
equal to the slope which we figured out
times x minus 5 and we're done
that's all and if you want out of
interest you could do the algebra to put
this into the slope intercept form to
the mx plus b form and see that they are
completely equivalent
let's do another one
so they gave us our slope it's
three-fifths and the y-intercept is
negative three so here immediately this
would be very easy to put in the slope
intercept form in slope intercept form
slope
intercept
intercept form the equation of this line
is y is equal to the slope
three-fifths x
plus the y-intercept minus three and
we'd be done but how do you put this
into y-intercept into point-slope form
so how do you do this into point-slope
slope
well we know the slope we know that m is
equal to three-fifths we know m is equal
to three-fifths but do we know any
points on this line you need a point and
a slope to immediately put into
point-slope form well we know one point
we know the y-intercept the y-intercept
is negative three that means when x is
equal to zero y is equal to negative
three so our point is the point zero
negative three you could have tried to
figure out other points you could say oh
when x is equal to 5 y is equal to 0.
there's all sorts of things you could
have tried out but this one was just
sitting there for us the y intercept is
negative 3 that means that the point 0
minus 3 is on the line
so let's write it in point slope form
y
minus
this y value so y minus negative 3
is equal to the slope
three fifths times x minus this x value
this x coordinate x minus zero
or if and this is point slope form we
could this could be y plus three is
equal to three fifths
times we could write times x minus zero
if you wanted to be you know you really
wanted to make it look like point-slope
form this would be point-slope form but
it's kind of silly to write x minus 0.
so you could just write y plus 3 is
equal to 3
fifths
x
you know but it's not 100 clear that
you're in point-slope form yet right now
but i think it's silly to write x minus
0. and obviously to go from here to
there you just have to subtract both
sides subtract 3 from both sides and
you'll get that so these are almost
equivalent i mean they are equivalent
in terms of what they represent they're
even almost equivalent in how you write
them you just have to subtract 3 from
both sides of this equation to get to
that one
let's do another one let's put this in
point slope form
so these they're giving us information
when x so they're giving it in the form
of x f of x
right
so in this situation when x is negative
seven
f of x is equal to five
and this coordinate they're telling us
when
x is equal to 3
f of x is equal to negative 4.
so just like that we can figure out the
slope first
so the slope
which is equal to change in x over
change in or sorry change in y over
change in x so let's do this it's
negative 4
minus
5
over
over
3
minus
negative 7
and this is going to be equal to
negative 4 minus 5 is negative 9
and then 3 minus negative 7 that's the
same thing as 3 plus 7 that's 10. so
slope is negative 9 10
and so to put this in point slope form
is really easy
point slope form point
slope
form is just going to be
y let's do it this way y
minus
a color coded 3
is equal to i'll do this in the back to
the green color is equal to
the slope is equal to negative 9
over 10
times
x
minus
this x minus this coordinate x minus
negative 4
then we can close it so this is in
point-slope form we obviously can
simplify this negative a little bit we
could rewrite it as
y minus 3 is equal to negative 9 10
times x
plus 4.
and we are done